ah hey stormy hi
hey kylie thank you so much for having
me over of course what a cute way to
start this video kylie jenner with a
little help from daughter stormy is
answering 73 questions for vogue it's
fun and she's revealing her biggest
keeping up with the kardashians regret
is there anything that you wish the
cameras hadn't seen
kylie's baby bump is also on full
display throughout the full video so
what were you doing before i got here
i made my daughter some breakfast and
then i had an ultrasound appointment wow
and aside from that ultrasound
appointment is this how a typical day
starts for you
every day is really different and what
do you normally prepare for breakfast
my favorite breakfast is something sweet
like a cinnamon roll or coffee cake yeah
the 24 year old makeup mogul is
answering all sorts of major questions
if my true fans or want to know personal
stuff then
it's just how it is which of your
siblings are you talking to the most
these days
we are on a family group chat all day so
we all talk the same amount who's the
most active on this family group chat
probably my mom who's the least
probably me which one makes you laugh
the hardest
rob rob always makes me laugh the
hardest i can see that and who's the
most like your mom
me i love it kylie even describes her
famous family members kim is loyal
chloe
chloe is gracious
courtney
she's very loving
kendall
kendall's confident
one word to describe your mom
strong i mean it's so much fun of course
kylie also talks a little bit about
keeping up with the kardashians
why do you think people love watching
your family
i think that they can always find
someone to relate to i can see that and
what is the craziest rumor that you've
heard about your family
that we are all actually bald
you kidding me yep
do you ever re-watch episodes of keeping
up with the kardashians once they're on
yes
what's the most important thing your
sisters taught you about being famous
i think that we're all still learning
and navigating through it i can't she
even reveals after 20 seasons there is
one moment she wishes never aired
probably my stripper pole episode
how did you learn how to do that
towards the end of the video we see mama
chris who also asks kylie a few
questions what was the best part about
growing up in a big family
never a dull moment
i'm obsessed with it so
yeah but still the part we're loving the
most is seeing kylie glow in that crop
top making sure we can all see that baby
number two is on the way she says she
and travis scott haven't picked out a
name just yet since they don't know the
sex of the baby we wanted to be really
organic and truly representing our
styles a source recently told et that
it's important to the couple that they
prepare stormy for her future siblings
they are making sure she knows how loved
she is and preparing her to be a big
sister by keeping her very engaged and
quote kylie can't wait to be a new mom
again she feels like she was born to be
a mom and can't wait to start another
chapter of her life with stormy and
travis by her side e.t couldn't be
happier to see kylie getting so candid
and can't wait for more from her growing
family
[Music]